mais non mais non via trois plus trois
légal 33 bon pour te racheter on va
faire un peu de zoologie
dis moi quel est le petit de la même
temps très bien du groupe
le bouquin de l'ours succès du lot
olympio bon alors maintenant on va
passer aux femelles les femelles la
femelle du saumon c'est nous la saumure
très bien du sanglier layette du
perroquet et rue du coq à coquette et du
gooc la barre on prévient un très bon
alors maintenant d'autres questions un
peu plus difficile pour pascal qu'est ce
qu'un capitaliste un habitant de la
capitale
oui et un centenaire il ne me quitte 700
francs oui très bien
catherine catherine qu est ce qu un
palmipède c'est un individu oui et les
bacs or ce sont des jeunes qui ont leur
bac
très bien qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
grève générale si quand les généraux
transrun oui et un soldat de carrière
c'était sympa café naguère dans des
quartiers très bien jacky jacky qu'est
ce que c'est que la jaunisse où j'aime
20 h 10 et que venir viré sa cuti
il ya koné ficher nos portes brigitte
une question très difficile
pourquoi dont la tête des sardines avant
de les mettre dans une boîte ton état
qu'elles doivent ni très bien et où
élèves dont les huîtres l'eau des
parkings
oui bon alors maintenant on va
interroger bernard bernard et fils
d'électricien il va très bien répondre
certainement à cette question qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un volts m
c'est un appareil qui sert à mesurer le
coin qui pense à un mètre de hauteur
excellent passe dans l'histoire de
france jérôme qui a repoussé les arabes
à poitiers
ils ont repoussé tout seul oui et
officiers
versailles contacter leur temps prévu
mais j'allais oublier vincent vincent
dix mois le défaut de celui qui est à va
'cela va la famille c'est très bien et
l'impératif du verbe se taire
jean-charles vous n'allez pas me
raconter ce sont les élèves de l'école
doit aussi qui vous ont donné toute la
matière de ce mardi l'écho non non non
absolument pas les élèves dont six ont
lu ses perles mardi les cancres et elles
ont essayé de vous amuser en les
résidents ici aujourd'hui il ya
quelqu'un qui va s'amuser la semaine
prochaine ça va être la solitaire j'ai
dû m'en porte avec les perles c'est très
formateur pour les enfants savent et oui
ça leur montre les erreurs à ne plus
faire et puis en plus quand il ya une
verve qui ne comprennent pas qu'il l'ait
fait part ils cherchent ensuite dans le
dictionnaire pour essayer de comprendre
qu'elle était là la réalité et ils sont
aussi devenus des auditeurs un peu trop
attractif puisque vous recueillez
maintenant les perles des maîtres jouini
et chats mais on attend on a autant
écouter dans les classes a songé que
pour prendre leur maître ou défaut les
enfants les cancres surtout d'ailleurs
écoute écoute et à noter les instruit
mais je crois que le mètre d'ici ne rien
donner comme ferme hélas non le mètre
d'ici ne fait pas de perles
mais heureusement d'autres maîtres
qu'ils en font et je voudrais vous en
citer une qui est ma préférée c'est un
proviseur qui arrive dans une classe
pour rendre une composition de
mathématiques il prend un air sévère il
dit je vois peu d'entre vous qui sont
dans les 10 premiers
[Musique]